STEVE: WELCOME TO NEXT
REVOLUTION, I AM STEPH STEVE HIL
THIS IS THE SHOW OF POPULAR.
WITH ME LIVE IN LOS ANGELES,
TOMMY, STEEFER STEVE AND KATRINA
JENNA IS HERE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP PRAISING ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER.
>> BUT FIRST, OVER AT THE JEFF
BEZOS POST, THEY SAY DEMOCRACY
DIES IN DARKNESS, IT IS TOO
LATE, YOU MAY HAVE MISSED IT,
OUR DEM DEMOCRACY DID DIE THIS W
THANK GOD, RACHEL WAS ON HAND TO
CHRONICAL THAT DEMISE.
>> JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
THROWN INTO CRISES AND CHAOS,
INSTITUTIONS WILL NOT SAVE YOU,
BUT WHAT DO WE DO NEXT?
WHAT DO WE DO?
WHAT DO WE DID ABOUT IT?
HOW DANGEROUS AND BAD THIS IS,
THE ALARMS ARE RINGS, THE
PRESIDENT RIPS THE SHIMS OUT SYS
BY THE ROOT.
THIS MUST BE STOPPED ALARMED
SURROUNDED, WE’RE AWAKE.
STEVE: SERIOUSLY.
OKAY, IT IS THAT KIND OF HIS --
HISSERHIS-- HYSTERICAL RANTING.
IF SHE BELIEVES IN PROTECTING
OUR DEMOCRACY, SHE SHOULD BE
PRAISING WHAT HAPPEN THIS WEEK.
THIS IS THE.
THEY USE TO APPOINT BASE SYSTEM
IN NOVEMBER ROGER STONE WAS
CONVICTED OF 7 FELONY COUNTS
GAVE HIM 21 POINTS ON THAT
TABLE, HE COLUMN 1, BECAUSE A
FIRST OFFENSE, THAT MEANS A
SENTENCING GUIDELINE.
3 TO 4 YEARS, NOW PROSECUTORS
CAN ADD POINTS FOR DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES, ONE IS IF A
DECONFIDENTTHREATENED A WITNESS
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE.
IT WAS INCREASED TO 29.
9 YEARS.
BUT THIS WAS A RIDICULOUSLY
LITERAL INTERPRETATION OF A
JOKE, THE WITNESS WHO WAS
ALLEGEDLY THREATENED TOLD COURT
HE DID NOT TAKE IT SERIOUSLY, AD
TO THAT PROSECUTOR MAKES
RECOMMENDATION HAD ANTI-TRUMP
POLITICAL BACKGROUND, AND U.S.
ATTORNEY FOR DC, OVERRULED THE
PROSECUTORS AND PROPOSED THE
MORE LEAN LENIENT SENTENCE, THIS
VITAL FACT LEFT OUT.
IT WAS MADE LAST WEEK NOT BY
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR, AND EVERY
ANYONE KNEW OR TWEETED ABOUT IT
THEN WHAT?
ACCORDING TO DOJSOURCES, THE 4
PROSECUTORS DID NOT LIKE BEING
OVERRULED SO THEY THREATENED TO
RESIGN, IN THE FACE OF THAT
THREAT, U.S. ATTORNEY TIM TIMOTH
SHEA REVERSED HIS DECISION AND
WENT WITH THE ORIGINAL 9 YEAR
RECOMMEND DOING, ONLY AT THAT
POINT THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR
INTERVENED.
TO BACK THE ORIGINAL JUDGMENT OF
THE U.S. ATTORNEY.
NOW, IN THE LIGHT OF THOSE
FACTS.
CONSIDER WHAT POLITICS SAID LAST
WEEK.
>> ON RULE OF LAW BY ENGAGING IN
POLITICAL INTERFEREENCE OF
SENTENCING.
-- TRUMP, RUSSIA TIES, AND
WITNESS TAMPERING, AG BARR HAS
DAMAGED THE RULE OF LAW.
STEVE: SO RIDICULOUS, SHE COULD
BARELY READ THE WORDS, WHAT
HAPPENED OF THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
SHE SAID.
YOU HAD A POLITICALLY MOTIVATED
INVESTIGATION.
INITIATE BY TRUMP HATERS, AIMED
AT OVERTURNING AN ELECTION
RESULT THEY DISAPPROVED OF,
INVESTIGATION FAILED TO
ESTABLISH THE CENTRAL CHARGE
FROM RUSSIA COLLUSION, BECAUSE
IT WAS FABRICATED, THEY
PROSECUTED A HANDFUL OF PROCESS
CRIMES IN STONE’S CASE IT WAS
NOT A FAIR TRIAL.
WITH A JURY WHO ARE BIASED
AGAINST HIM, HE WAS CONVICTED
AND SENTENCE RECOMMENDED, WAS
WAY OUT OF WHACK.
IF YOU WANT TO SEE ABU ABUSE OF
POWER, JUST LOOK AT LAST 3 YEARS
WHERE SOME MOST POWERFUL
INSTITUTION IN COUNTRY, FBI,
CIA, JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
CONGRESS HAVE BEEN CORRUPTED TO
PURSUE A POLITICAL VENDETTA, NOT
BY PRESIDENT TRUMP, BUT AGAINST
HIM.
NOW, WE HAVE AN ATTORNEY GENERAL
MOIS STANDING UP -- WHO IS
STANDING UP FOR RULE OF LAW,
FREE OF POLITICAL INTERFERENCE,
AND PRESIDENT IS FIGHTING BACK,
AGAINST THE RESISTANCE INSIDE OF
HIS ADMINISTRATION.
THE ESTABLISHMENT WENT NUTS
ABOUT THAT TOO.
>> HE FIRED -- THREW VINDMAN’S
BROTHER, THEY SAID IT WAS
AWKWARD TO KEEP THEM.
THAT WOULD PROVE TO BE ALLY.
>> THAT CAPPING A WEEK OF
IMPEACHMENT REVENGE FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW,
PRESIDENT IS NOW ACTING HE IS.
STEVE: EVEN PRESIDENT’S FORMER
CHIEF OF STAFFION -- JOHN KELLI
JOINED IN.
WHAT A JOKE.
HOW LONG DO YOU THINK JOHN KELLY
WOULD HAVE TOLERATED A SOLDIER
IN HIS RECOMMEND REGIMENT TO GET
POLICIES THAT WAS VOTED FOR IN
AN ELECTION, WE TRIED TO STOP
HIM BUILDING A WALL.
>> HE IS VERY DEFINITELY CHANGED
HIS ATTITUDE TOWARD THE DACA
ISSUE AND THE WALL.
ONCE WE BRIEFED HIM.
STEVE: ONCE WE BRIEFED HIM.
STEVE: I AM SORRY WHO ELECTED
JOHN KELLY TO COUNTER VOTES.
THE SAME-- PRESIDENT GETS A LOT
OF GRIEF FOR HIS TWEETING.
BUT THINK ABOUT WHY HE NEEDS
THAT DIRECT COMMUNICATION, WHAT
HE IS UP AGAINST.
AS WE NOTED HE IS A PROG PRAGMAT
PROBLEM -- SOLVING PRESIDENT.
HE THINKS NEED TOO GET IT DONE
BUT NOT WITH THESE JOKERS, 1 ONC
INS WHITE HOUSE HE IS VOWNTDEDI
SURROUNDED BY PEOPLE TRYING TO
STOP HIM FROM HIS PROMISES.
TOO OFTEN IT WAS DISAGREE THEN
RESIST.
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP GETTING
ELECTED WAS EASY PART, THE EASE
BATTLE WAS WITH SWAMP WHEN HE
GOT THERE.
THE CRITICS SAY, WHY DID THEY
GIVE JOBS TO JARED AND IRK IVANK
BECAUSE HE COULD TRUST THEM TO
WORK FOR HIM NOT AGAINST HIM,
THEY ARE THE ONES GETTING THINGS
DONE.
LIKE USMCA WITH HEIGHT LIGHTHIZE
AND ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR, A
COURAGEOUS LEADER, LONG MAY HE
STAY.
>> A TRUMP SECOND TERM, THE
PRESIDENT NEED ONLY PEOPLE LIKE
THIS.
ONLY PEOPLE COMMITTED TO HIS
AGENDA,  CLEAR OUT THE
BUREAUCRATIC RESISTANCE, NO MORE
SWAMP STOOGES, NO MORE ARROGANT
ENTITLED KNOW ALLS WHO THINK
THEY HAVE RIGHT TO BLOCK
POLICIES THAT 53 MILLION
AMERICANS VOTED FOR.
FIRE THEM ALL, DRAIN THE SWAMP,
BLOW OF THE BUREAUCRACY, SES IS
DECIMATE THE CIVIL SERVICE, I
MEAN LITERALLY, POWER TO PEOPLE,
SCHOOL CHOICE, LOWER TAXES, LESS
REGULATION, CALLED CIVIL CALL
SELF-GOVERNMENT, THAT IS THE
NEXT REVOLUTION WE NEED, THAT IS
THE LESSON OF THIS WEEK.